- [Instructor] Let's say we're
trying to figure out what two
divided by
1/10 is.
So pause this video and see
if you can have a go at that.
All right, now there's a couple of ways
that we could approach this.
We could just try to think of
everything in terms of tenths,
since we're dividing by 1/10.
And so instead of two ones,
we could rewrite that two
as the same thing as 20/10,
20/10
divided by,
divided by, and I could
rewrite this as 1/10.
And so, if you have 20 of something
and if you want to divide it into groups
of one of that something,
how many groups are you going to have?
Well, you're going to have 20 groups,
so this is going to be equal to 20.
So that's interesting.
Two divided by 1/10 is equal to twenty.
Now, what if I were to take, I don't know,
I'm just gonna make up another number.
Let's say if I were to
take seven divided by,
divided by 1/10.
What is that going to be equal to?
Well, same idea.
Seven ones is the same thing as seventy
tenths.
And if I divide that by
one
tenth,
well, 70 of something divided into groups
of one of that something is
going to be 70 equal groups.
So this is going to be equal to
70.
So seven divided by 1/10 is equal to 70.
Two divided by 1/10 is equal to 20.
You might notice a pattern.
Now there's other ways that
we could've approached this.
We could've said something
like two divided by 1/10
is the same thing as two over 1/10,
and I could write 1/10 like that.
And so when you divide by a fraction,
that's the same thing as
multiplying by the reciprocal.
So this is the same thing as
two times,
two times 10.
And then that pattern might
be a little bit clearer,
which is going to be equal to 20.
When you divide by a tenth,
it's the same thing as multiplying by 10.
Same thing happened over here,
when we divided by a tenth,
it was the same thing as
multiplying seven by 10
to get to 70.
So what do you think is going to happen
if we divide by a hundredth?
So let's say I have six.
And I am going to...let me make
that into a different color.
So let's say I have six,
and I want to divide that by
a hundredth.
Pause this video, and see
if you can figure that out.
Well, one way to approach it
is we can express everything
in terms of hundredths.
So... I really enjoy saying hundredths.
Hundredths! (chuckles)
So six could be rewritten as,
each whole is equal to
a hundred hundredths,
so six wholes, or six ones,
is going to be equal to 600 hundredths.
So this is going to be
equal to 600 hundred
hundredths, hundredths (chuckles),
and then that's going to be divided
into equal groups of one hundredth.
Hundredth.
So if I have 600 of
something and I'm dividing it
into equal groups of
one of that something,
how many equal groups am I going to have?
Well, I'm going to have 600 equal groups.
Now another way that we
could've approached this
is we could've approached
it with fractions.
We could've said hey, this
thing is the same thing
as six
over one hundredth,
which I could express like this,
which is equal to six times the
reciprocal of one hundredth.
So that's six times the
reciprocal of one hundredth,
which is one hundred over one,
or we could just write that as 100,
which once again gets us to 600.
So maybe you're seeing a pattern again.
When you divide by a hundredth,
that's equivalent to
multiplying by a hundred.
When you divide by a tenth,
that's the equivalent
as multiplying by 10.
So I'll leave you there.
I encourage you to think about that some.